the key to learning online is actually
the same key that has always been to
learning is that you have to take
ownership over it yourself a lot of
people have you know there's this
illusion that is created in our
classical education system and even at
the university that someone is is
teaching it to you really they're
creating a context in which you can need
to pull information and own it yourself
and that you know especially happens at
the university level where if you're not
pulling and if you're not owning it
you're not you're not going to do so
well and when you think online that
becomes that much more important because
you can create the best software and the
best video but unless you set your own
goals and you apply you know some of the
work from Carol Dweck at Stanford your
own growth mindset unless you exhibit
grit and perseverance where you keep
trying until you get something then even
though the fancy software is not going
to be of a ton of value and so what we
do as creators is we try to make that
easier for the core the consumer of the
content so it Khan Academy we do a lot
of trying to virtually coach someone to
have the right mindset to to be
perseverant with things and you know one
thing that we strongly believe is videos
you can learn from but even if you're
just looking at a video or reading an
article try to do so actively don't just
passively listen to it pause it try to
solve it yourself once you figure out
what the person making the video is
about to do pause it and see if you
could do it yourself review it yourself
and ideally there would be exercises and
this is actually where most of Khan
Academy's investment is is unlimited
exercises that give people feedback and
unlimited practice to make sure that
they really do understand the material
and allows them to review it in a space
repetition way so they can understand
when do they apply which skills so it
really is the active the active
listening active learning and the
practicing and getting feedback and
reviewing that's and then actually
applying it in your everyday life
through projects and then whatever